Naples, technically an independent kingdom in the 1700s and early 1800s,...
...was filled with working poor or "lazzaroni."
Unlike the wealthy minority,...
...these working class Neapolitans needed cheap and quick food.
Pizza met this need.
Whether it's breakfast, lunch or dinner,...
...pizza was sold by street vendors at informal restaurants...
...and featured the toppings that are still popular today...
...like tomatoes, cheese, anchovies, oil and garlic.
Despite a stamp of approval from the crown,...
...pizza remained little-known in Italy beyond the border of Naples...
...until the 1940s.
An ocean away however,...
...Neapolitan immigrants were already replicating and popularizing pizza.
And the United States already had its first licensed pizzeria by 1905.
From there, pizza has slowly taken over the world,...
...become one of the most popular and well-known foods today.